maintenant l'heure de la météo est
aujourd'hui alain gillot-pétré un
complice oui j'ai un complice qui a émis
le désir de faire cette météo avec moi
c'est qu'on puisse prestigieux puisqu'il
s'agit de monsieur de monsieur jean
poiret suis heureux de vous accueillir
ou à faire une météo à la carte écoutez
vous écoutez ça me fait ça me fait un
grand plaisir vous n'avez pas de menu
vous ne fait qu'à la carte uniquement à
l'as karaté adapté à la tête du client
elle autorise bien entendu bah moi je
suis venu parce que j'aurais voulu pour
vous poser des questions sur vont
sûrement quartier sur mon secteur sur ma
rue parce que fait que ceux voulant
reprise qui se passe ce qui se passe au
pays basque tout ça dans le nord c'est
très bien mais je voudrais savoir si non
je ne m'en fiche pas mais comme je ça
devrait me dis je vais je vais dans
trois endroits alors je voudrais savoir
dans l'immédiat quel va être le temps au
dessus de la rue spontini dans le xvième
la rue spontini ben vous aurez les
nuages de romorantin le soleil de
barfleur et les températures de
lunéville oui pas de micro climat
est alors j'irai au bazar de l'hôtel de
ville faire des achats vers 3h vers 3h
vous êtes tenté par un orage sur l'hôtel
de ville voyez sur l'hôtel de ville sur
la rue de solférino izard très bien et
alors je finirai je finirai dans la
soirée vers la vers la porte d'italie je
vous les conseille très fortement ah bon
très lentement plus la porte de
châtillon plus tôt ah bon parce que je
vois je vois une échappée de soleil vers
le vers le sud la rue mais vous savez à
21h c'est un peu léger pour le soleil il
énonce un chien allait plutôt porte de
châtillon bon pas très bien je peux
c'est pour ça que je préfère avoir des
endroits mais direct avec vous je suis
comme vous donnez le rêve si vous pouvez
me donner le reste pouvez-vous bionest
pour vous fournir une enveloppe aussi
mais enfin ça on verra après pour sa
part donc pour aujourd'hui chers amis
cette fois nous sommes sérieux lance le
ciel sera dans l'ensemble variable avec
encore de l'instabilité ce qui signifie
de la pluie des orages locaux
éventuellement de la grêle et oui que
voulez vous des éclaircies dans la masse
et à partir de 12 cents mètres vous
aurez de la neige sur la méditerranée et
bien ce pas trop mauvais à cause d'un
vent de nord à nord-ouest modéré donc
c'est du beau temps sur le golfe du lion
sauf petits effets locaux il nous reste
maintenant les températures je me rendre
à écouter voyons les températures sont à
l'autre écoutez moi c'était très bien
cet étrange 36,8 ce matin en france
j'étais très bien soin de rechercher pas
combien je mange ce soir mes compliments
à madame les températures seront toutes
façons en baisse aujourd'hui mais elle
reste quand même un peu au dessus des
normes saisonnières non nous allons de
10 à 14 degrés sur la moitié nord 14 à
paris 13e rue spontini oui et de 12 à 18
degrés sur la moitié sud comme vous le
voyez 18° à perpignan où c'est où ça ça
c'est la corsa oui j'ai tout fait pour
action sébastien
toujours ils ont toujours quand même des
températures élevées un oui très bien
merci monsieur pour être leur fenêtre
météo avec moi et bien écoutez merci
vous embrassiez tout le monde le ma part
je n'y manquerai pas merci
[Musique]